amore amore pazzo se pazzesca more tv
guarda chi vedo raggiante amore icap
secchi no amore ma guarda che il caffè
guarda guarda che non solo se chiesto no
nel senso questi qui che tu vedi così
non sono capelli rotti sono quelli sotto
che stanno rifacendo c'è un ricambio
generazionale del cappello ti sei
lasciata
non ci credo ma non stavate per sposare
no ma io guarda una come te non la
ritroverà mai più poi con questi capelli
c'è mamma poi capito con la tua migliore
amica non me l'hai appena detto tu che
che chi ha tradito con la migliore amica
e allora l'ho immaginato o la vedi con
la capone entrata minchia quella coi
capelli che sembra uno spaventapasseri
minchia ti giuro che è stata tradita dal
marito il giorno del matrimonio che
elogi te lo giuro ma non è capito
l'hanno beccato in bagno con la sua
miglior amica
capito mincato più tradimento ma ti
rendi con la gente comunque non ce la fa
più poveri la si vede che sta male ma
donna guarda quante secca però capito
almeno di bari esce comunque quando
soffri così tanto li perdi che magari
che trovavo anche io uno che mi faceva
dimagrire o ogni volta che mi fidanzo
mica sbocco che dobbiamo cioè cosa in
che modo ti posso aiutare no ma non è
questione di punte cara io sai sono una
persona molto sincera quindi te lo dirò
proprio sinceramente
proprio sono da radere al suolo questi
capelli ed alle punte alla cute anche
guarda anche la forma del cranio non è
quella corretta cioè non va bene se vuoi
farti la piega con questi capelli vai
qua davanti dai parquet del brand 10
euro che loro pettinano chiunque nel mio
salone e io questi capelli non li posso
trattare proprio una questione di etica
morale abbastanza consolidata negli anni
ok allora discutiamo un pochino ok
andiamo magari su un biondo cenere ti
potrebbe piacere idea o che ai perfetti
ci penso io che dici scurire abbiamo
scurito io trovo che ti stiano molto
bene
chen o biondo cenere è passato di moda
amore e guarda top ragazzi non è top top
ve lo dico tutti totti 80 aut aut aut
spuntatina 2 mm ok perfetto ci penso io
amore ma quali 20 centimetri ma ho tolto
soltanto le puntine rovinate guardo
adesso sono molto molto più pieni molto
più belli toc toc toc toc eccoci amore
allora allora cambiamo un po dai dai
amore dai sento lo percepisco nell'aria
un po di cambiamento quasi sa che
lasciata ogni volta che una si lascia
deve cambiare un po muore muore
ascoltami un attimo caschetto e
destrutturato che va di modissima lo
facciamo mogano
anzi no anzi lo facciamo vecchio con
latte fondente e sulle punte poi in rete
al latte span o no scusa scusa allora
una cosa ancora più rivoluzionaria
questo colore qua con le puntine verdi
lo so che così il pc demand in area ma
guarda guarda capito come c'è la cui o
jennifer lopez ed ai amore cara come di
no visto rito amante allora secondo me
aversa da uno shampoo un pochino più
nutriente tipo questo qui in questo qui
dove nutrire bene la fibra e come
maschera allora guarda io vi consiglio
questa qui perché farsi girare bene le
punte a togliere tutto l'effetto crespo
ok amore fa cosa devi fare per
asciugarli come piacciono a te allora
turi lavi concrete assen giu capello
umido applichi questo poi sulle punte
questo sulla cute queste lo massaggi
bene fin quando non si assorbe poi
spruzzi dopo la tv a questo qui allora
in totale questi qui più uno shampoo la
massima sono 359 euro ma.car affidati
fidati che mi ringrazierai